i want to read this from your book so
who is a nice guy this is what you say
his relative
he is the relative who lets his wife run
the show he is the friend who will do
anything for anybody but whose own life
seems to be in shambles he is the guy
who frustrates his wife because he's
afraid of conflict that nothing
ever gets resolved he is the boss who
tells one person
what they want to hear then re reverses
himself to please someone else he is the
man who lets people walk all over him
because he doesn't want to rock the boat
he is the dependable guy at work who
will never say
no but would never tell anyone if they
were imposing on him and then
characteristics of a nice guy
nice guys seek the approval of others
they try to hide their uh perceived
flaws and mistakes
they put other people's needs and wants
before them they sacrifice their own
personal power and often play the world
victim
they tend to be disconnected from other
men and from their own masculine energy
they co-create relationships that are
less than satisfying
they create situations in which they do
not have very much good sex
and they frequently fail to live up to
their full potential
so now when this nice guy gets married
married what does life look like for a
nice guy like this
i can tell you i've been there yeah
typically he's trying to please his
partner
trying to make her happy trying to avoid
conflict
a real big manifestation of this is
where he won't bring up
anything that might upset her so he
won't tell her the whole truth about
stuff he'll leave things out
which as you probably know if you if you
want to really upset or trigger a woman
let her find out something that you
hadn't told her about and uh
that that just messes with the trust um
so yeah is that is that avoidance of
conflict the dishonesty the trying to
please the hiding of things
from her that you don't want her to find
out and and in terms of sex
it's usually just a lot of pleasing and
trying to get them into the mood
it's kind of like well you know sneaking
your sexual agenda up on her or giving
her the back rub
hoping that you know she'll be okay with
that and then sneaking your hand around
to the side of her breast to see if you
know
if she gives a negative reaction or
approval you just offended 95
of men around the world they're going
that's my technique that's my that's my
skill set
um and and that stuff you know the woman
knows what we're doing oh he's giving me
the back rub because he's open blah blah
blah blah blah
and and that doesn't tend to turn most
women on
but we think we got to sneak our agenda
up on them
and so what happens is is i find that
most women
you know most women you mentioned
earlier about when they respond to my
book the majority of women
really like the book you know when it
was published in 2003
barnes and noble the publisher thought
oh this is going to stir up a real
feminist storm it never happened you
know i
maybe have gotten in 19 years six angry
emails from women
almost all of them haven't read the book
but maybe their husband or boyfriend
did and broke up with them and now
they're going ballistic because it's my
book's fault that the
and you know i'm thinking when i'm
reading the email go run
guy run i'd see why you left this woman
so
i mean women like the idea of a man
being honest
authentic assertive setting the tone and
leading
having a plan showing up with their
sexuality
you know is full force you know right
there and and
most women are going to respond better
to that
than the guy this hidden secretive
pleasing placating avoiding
yeah that's just not a turn on so so can
we categorize what's good
sex what's bad sex oh that's that's a
good topic to jump into
um i think good sex would probably be
the kind that everybody wants to keep
having again
um that'd be good sex bad sex
in in my experiences when is anxiety
ridden
guilt-ridden shame written um
approval written performance written i
tell men
i hate it when i hear the word sexual
and performance
used in the same sentence sex is not a
performance
sex is showing up and enjoying each
other's bodies
i mean that that's to me is good sex uh
you know i'm enjoying my partner's body
while she's enjoying my body
it doesn't get any better than that and
if it's uninhibited
wait are you saying like timeline
doesn't matter with performance
you and her both being satisfied you
know
you're saying performance is not tied to
good sex so if you do yours
and you're like listen i got mine it was
amazing you light up that little
cigar cigarette and she's sitting there
empty-handed saying dude
what's this all about you call that sex
well and here's the thing you know we
can do a deep dive into this i
i think sex and if you know there's
there's a lot of really good
writers out there from dr david snarch
book called passionate marriage he just
passed away a few weeks ago
uh david dada the way of superior man
osho
uh raja nish who had you know out in
oregon had that
that clan out there just from some great
great writings
about sex being the most powerful
container for us to do our deepest
work as human beings because sex is at
the core
of who we are you know sex is how we got
to be on this planet
uh so it's at the core of who we are so
if we can use sex
if a man and woman man and man woman and
woman doesn't matter how you're paired
up
can can consciously approach sex as as i
call
as a powerful personal growth machine
not just a way to get off not just a way
to get some validation not just a way to
get our partners approval
but as a powerful personal growth
machine everything that shows up in that
container
is is good everything that shows up in
there is opportunity to do our deepest
work
we're not going to do there's nothing
else in life that's going to help us do
deeper work
than a conscious sexual container with
another conscious partner
so of course everybody's got to be
enjoying this but i found that when
what happens with a lot of nice guys
especially they they fall into what i
call the white guy shuffle
and and why i call it that is i took
salsa dance lessons for a few years up
in the seattle area
and in that in that particular area the
the term for a guy that just
kind of keeps doing the same move over
and over again
it's called the white guy shuffle i i it
seems appropriate because i
i kind of tended to do that oh i don't
want to risk i don't know that move real
well i'll just keep doing the one i know
and i i had a chinese salsa teacher a
guy named jim chow in seattle so props
to jim chow
mr channel he used to interrupt every
class
and shout at the guys leads be thinking
ahead
what is your next move two or three
moves ahead because if you don't
you're gonna repeat the same old thing
and the woman's gonna get bored and go
find someone else to dance with
and every time he said that i said amen
because that's true about sex so what
happens
here's what a lot of nice guys do they
they do like i said the back rub
the the sneak the sex up on her and and
they go okay i want her to want to have
sex with me again
so i'm going to do what worked last time
i know if i kind of tweaked her nipple
this way last time and then
they kind of went down on her a little
bit and then did that she got off so
i'm gonna do that next time because that
worked the last time
and do you know how quickly that gets
boring to a woman
you know how quickly she's gonna go find
another dance partner
when we show up with the same moves
every time
and so it's that white guy shuffle most
women
long term in relationship a primary
reason a lot of them lose interest in
sex is not because they don't like sex
they just lose interest in the same damn
thing every time
i mean i i have no idea what your wife
is like
but you know can she wear the same
outfit to work
in one in a month you know you can
probably wear the same suit
twice a week right she would never do
that
how often does she change her nails do
her hair differently how often does she
want to rearrange the furniture go shoe
shopping
for shoes that she doesn't need but yeah
oh this would be so great with this
outfit
that the feminine needs that variety to
fill it
and if we're gonna approach our woman
and bring the same old thing every time
and throw that down and think that's
gonna you know make her want to come
back for more
it doesn't but here's here's the the
paradox the irony
if two people don't have agendas and are
not trying to perform
and each time they get together is just
an exploration of what feels good
what what's cool about this person's
body with my body oh that that seems to
be getting us off or
or you know what what stories can i tell
this person to get them aroused or what
and and in his play and as we learn to
be in our bodies and pay attention
and move the sexual energy around and
and and play with it with each other
i mean is it that's good sex that's fun